[Music]
[Applause]
spring in brandel chamblee the lead golf
channel studio analyst live from augusta
analysis throughout the day and in prime
time each night
best piece of sports memorabilia you
have is what brandel
let me think about that
i think i got a a-rod
uh signed baseball
that's not bad uh let's see um gosh i'm
not much of a big
sports memorabilia collector uh i got a
piece of art
uh a beautiful piece of art signed by
arnold palmer it was a pencil sketching
of him at the 1960 open championship
where he finished second
from a
very famous painter in europe by the
name of harold riley
and and believe it or not i had that for
about 20 years and a good friend of mine
is great friends with jack nicholson
and uh jack nicholson was having i think
his 70th birthday party
and he loves art jack nicholson does so
i was like all right i'll uh i'll give
this to my buddy to give to jack
nicholson and so i'm assuming it hangs
in jack nicholson's house yeah
nicholson's got quite an art collection
yeah he loves it and he loves his golf
i have um
uh when tiger won the grand slam i have
an autograph of
let's see
augusta the augusta newspaper but tiger
will autograph it to you
instead of just putting tiger woods
where you could sell it it's like
to dan
all the best tiger woods well that's
pretty good right there yeah that's
pretty good
no one's ever done that he personalized
it for you and then tom brady sent me a
jersey
and it just it says to dan tom brady so
i can't unless somebody named dan wants
to buy it i'm not going to be able to
sell it um listen your whole room there
is a sports memorabilia hall of fame
probably yep it's pretty good it's
eclectic though there are a lot of
things where you go why would you
collect that
i mean i i famously or infamously
brought back a piece of turf from
augusta in the mid-90s when i played it
i i put in my golf bag in a baggie and
brought back a
a divot
see that's something you should just
plant in your yard nurture it then you
could claim your front yard was you know
augusta like
i mentioned this to start the show there
was a moment watching tiger yesterday
where
i think he felt like he won already he's
already won he got here he had a goal to
play in the masters nobody thought it
was possible he played well
you know no issues with his back the
hard part is just walking to his shots
he was scrambling he was here in the
roars nearly had a hole in one like it
just felt like you could see that in his
mind like
i'm playing with house money now
whatever happens from here
i did it i got i got through this round
and i'm under par
yeah i couldn't agree more you know
everything he was doing i i had in the
back of my mind
the video or the picture of the wreckage
in the bottom of that canyon and and
thinking first of all it was a miracle
he didn't die and it sounds like it was
a miracle he didn't lose his limb so in
the context of that i was thinking it's
a miracle that he's even here and then
when he looked to be and people say look
he he only shot one under so pumped the
brakes and he only hit nine greens you
know yesterday john romilly had nine
greens more cow only hit nine greens
matsuyama only at niagara it was very
hard to hit greens yesterday but it was
just how doggone sharp he was with his
golf game the top 20 players in the
world only five of them beat him
and you think about those top 20 players
in the world in the last 14 months all
they've been doing is thinking about
golf and working out and thinking about
their swings and sharpening
and he's been in rehab just trying to
walk
so in the context of that as i was
watching him
i thought okay it's a miracle he's here
but now 83 is in play
you know 83 wins he looked like a player
who could win again on the pga tour and
i think his
like
it seems like his rightful place is to
be the winningest golfer of all time
he's tied with sam snead at 82 i thought
that's where he was going to be after i
saw the wreck
but now i think 83 is in play
the conditions today as opposed to
yesterday today is going to be
much firmer much faster golf course is
going to be
a bit of a nightmare to play i mean it's
going to yesterday i mean the scores
were pretty i mean the scoring average
was almost 74. don't get me wrong but
there were plenty of really good scores
18 players i think broke broke par don't
think we'll see that today i mean 71
today will be
really good score 70 will move you way
up the leaderboard
if tiger came out today and he's gonna
probably be in the worst part of the
draw he's going to tee off right about
when the wind is anticipated to start
really blowing so tiger came out today
and shot
72-71
something like that he'd probably
maintain his spot maybe even move up a
little bit i know we've talked about
just how hilly that course is the
different levels there the winds are
tricky because i've pointed out to this
audience that i remember being on 12t
looking at the flag at 11 and the trees
on the t-box at 13
and the wind on 12 and they look like
they were all three different
the the winds are really it feels like
underrated at augusta you people i don't
think normally talk or you know factor
that in
so the wind that was blowing yesterday
you know it was a west wind but if it
just turned a little bit more towards
north but that's kind of the wind where
it could easily get in your face at 12.
there's a real a funny story about
winds blowing as severe as they were
yesterday in 1956
this player by the name of bob rossberg
got up there and they were blowing so
hard he had hit a foreign
he so he hits warren the wind stops
right when he hits it and the ball goes
over the green over the hill over the
trees over the fence and lands on the
ninth tee of augusta country club so 80
yards over the grain so he waits just a
minute
uses the same club hits a four and five
feet in the hole so i mean that's how
baffling it can be when you're on that t
so you're standing and you think well
everything hangs in the balance on this
one shot and i honestly don't know where
it's gonna go when i hit it so it's it's
uh
it's not a fun feeling i mean it's a
beautiful hole
but uh
i mean more i mean more people have have
evoked the lord's name
in vain
on and and and bowed and
genuflected to him on that t
tiger's post-round interviews also
fascinated me
because i've i've been in those moments
with him when he can shut you down where
he might go yes or no
he was effusive
like he don't you think he wanted to
talk
yeah i i think it seems to me that tiger
is
so appreciative in these
comebacks of his even
even in 2019-18 i i felt like he was
he was more open i think he's very
appreciative
you know i guess when he was
in the height of his competitive grade
you know his peers they were they were
he was competing against him but now he
comes back and i think everybody wants
to put their arms and just thank tiger
woods for what he's meant to the game of
golf thank them for the entertainment
value he's brought to them and i think
tiger now in the sort of sunset of his
career is appreciative for the
opportunity to play more and is
appreciative for
the love that he feels from the
spectators and i i i just think it's
made him a little bit softer and his
interviews now
i mean if you just dropped out of space
and never saw tiger woods before these
interviews you'd think he was the nicest
most heartwarming greatest guy gracious
superstar you've ever seen
i think he wants to let you in a little
bit more to let you know what he's gone
through
and i think his kids have softened him i
i think that that's the it just feels
like
you know you can be tiger woods to
everybody else but when you're home your
dad and it feels like he's brought a
little dad out onto the golf course with
him
no doubt you know i it's funny i i've
often said about tiger like i don't play
golf with him if you i don't know tiger
at all but i know that
his friends are some of the nicest
people you're gonna have no to be gay on
this show here in a little bit right
yeah uh
no to begins about the nicest human
being you'll ever meet in your life uh
steve stricker his good friend mark
o'mara
john cook these are these are literally
the nicest guys you will ever meet in
your life those are his friends
and
you know how could he be a bad guy with
those guys
as his friends uh and i know that when
he played the tour you know i i
talked to people who played with it was
like how was it you're like oh he's he's
great he's incredible you know he
doesn't putt out you know he doesn't
putt out and run off to the next tee
leaving you to put amidst the chaos of
everybody leaving the green you know
he's very respectful of the people he
plays with quick to say good shot and
they hit a good shot you know he's not
he's not going to yuck it up out there
with you because he's got business to
take care of but he's respectful and i
and and the fans
i i don't know if they fully realize
that but the players do and the players
love that about him uh they're called
patrons randall
[Laughter]
thank you dave i'm just saying
you know what i'll edit that out for the
podcast so i don't want you getting in
trouble
i appreciate that in my ear if i if i
just said fans on the air i had a
producer in my ear go up patrons but so
thank you dan your host and producer
um
i liked cam
smith to win it um
give me your pick after day one
yeah be tough to beat uh cam smith uh
but i i'll go sheffler uh you know i
just think scheffler drives the ball
better than cam smith it's it's not like
driving is hugely important at augusta
national in terms of finding fairways
but cam's got a wild miss to the left
about once a day waiting to happen
uh it happened a few times yesterday and
made double bogey in both of those
instances and scheffler is just a little
better driver of the golf ball and i
think in the end that'll be the
difference
great to talk to you tell the boys i
said hello we'll be watching later on
today
thanks dan nice talking to you that's
randall chamblee the lead golf channel
studio analyst
live for the masters must see tv every
single night